hi I'm stage and now screens lin-manuel
Miranda and I'm doing the wired
autocomplete interview his lin-manuel
Miranda gonna get through this interview
live Puerto Rican that's a big yes
Wepa and II got not yet
II got is a made-up term that reporters
like to use to characterize ones
self-worth
I have a Pulitzer Prize in MacArthur
Genius grant but if I don't have those
four letters
nothing is lin-manuel Miranda a tenner I
am but man I miss the days when I was a
first soprano in hunter elementary
school chorus is lin-manuel Miranda in
rent not yet December 24th 9 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time this is my
audition oh it's a no I'm sorry
Italy meanwhile Miranda nice that's
really sweet the kids wonderfully
autocompletes is that real if I wasn't
nice to you one day I was probably
running to the bathroom I'm sorry that's
half the time I'm rude to pee but I just
really have to go to the bathroom
what is lin-manuel Miranda I saw stop .
i'm have to pull this off
what does lin-manuel miranda its
favorite food i guess it depends on the
day but I'll take a chicken pad thai any
day I'll take a penne alla vodka
basically carbs what is lin-manuel
Miranda's a favorite Hamilton Alexander
song that changes every day I'm
relearning the lyrics right now as I
prepare to go back into the role for a
few weeks in Puerto Rico
my favorite song is wait for it because
I don't have any lyrics in it
what is the pitman while moran does
zodiac sign Capricorn and right now
you're saying Oh such a Capricorn what
color write lin-manuel Miranda's eyes
sort of mid-level shade of poop brown
what was lin-manuel Miranda's first
musical the first musical I ever wrote
was for an eighth-grade project based on
hind poo talks the chosen it was three
songs and I got a name this is fun poo
inspired lin-manuel Miranda everybody
I'm looking in my brain it's as this
file not found
who did lin-manuel Miranda play in the
Little Mermaid nobody but as a child the
one I related to the most of Sebastian
the crab and I think as an adult he's
still the one I relate to the most he's
he just wanted someone to sing in his
concerts poor guy he's a frustrated
musician I relate when did lin-manuel
Miranda cut his hair literally the
moment I stepped off stage from my final
performance in Hamilton Fred my hair guy
at Hamilton was ready with the Clippers
and we chopped it off and here we are
how old does lin-manuel Miranda son I
have a four year old and a ten month old
that didn't go where I thought it was
gonna go can lin-manuel Miranda pay off
my credit card debt can lemon will
Miranda run for president I'd rather do
anything I'd rather eat this poster
board is what men want Miranda I don't
know some days I don't know guys
is lin-manuel Miranda a descendent of
Hamilton oh he wasn't that that's
misspelt in the autofill I am NOT but
I've met them very nice is lin-manuel
Miranda writing music for Mary Poppins
no I'm very happy to report that the
music for Mary Poppins returns is
written by the great Marc Shaiman and
Scott Whitman and I get to sing the
songs is lin-manuel Miranda going on
tour I will be doing Hamilton in Puerto
Rico in January I'm only on one stop of
that tour I'll go raise a ton of money
for Puerto Rico and then that tour goes
on to San Francisco from there is
lin-manuel Miranda knighted hello how am
I allowed to be knighted busily Memo
Miranda writing another musical
constantly no more does lin-manuel
Miranda does he ever does lin-manuel
Miranda have an Instagram no totally
Manuel Miranda speaks Spanish does
lin-manuel Miranda respond to fan mail I
do my best
I'm very backlogged does lin-manuel
Miranda have any siblings
yes I have an older sister she's six
years older her name is loose it was
just her birthday a couple days ago does
with Manuel Miranda live in Washington
Heights
yes wrote a whole show about how much I
liked it does lin-manuel Maria
play an instrument yes I write on piano
I wish I could play guitar but I just
can't seem to develop the calluses for
it
what did lin-manuel Miranda see this is
now genuinely frightening to me what I'm
gonna pull up here what did lin-manuel
Miranda win a Grammy for one for in the
heights one for Hamilton and I've won
for Moana I'm very proud of all of those
what inspired
lin-manuel Miranda to write Hamilton Ron
chernow is great biography of Hamilton
you can buy that anywhere books are sold
what Hogwarts houses lin-manuel Miranda
I both self-identify as Slytherin and I
took the Pottermore test that literally
I didn't even know this was possible it
just said you're so Slytherin so
slithering what was lin-manuel Miranda's
first job I worked at the cashier the
cash register at the McDonald's on 91st
and Columbus Avenue I also worked in the
Playland space on family nights and
painted kids faces and did story time I
was much better at the story time than
the kids face you have never seen
disappointment like the kids walking
away from my face painting jobs what
college to lin-manuel Miranda go chip
I'm a proud graduate of Wesleyan
University in Middletown Connecticut go
Wes how tall is lin-manuel Miranda I'm
five nine and a little bit depending on
the heel where did lin-manuel Miranda go
to high school a proud graduate of
Hunter College High School in Manhattan
New York
how did lin-manuel Miranda peel this off
get his name my name was the subject of
a poem by a Puerto Rican poet and my dad
read the poem when he was 12 years old
it's called Nana Roja but I'm me baby
Ling McGuinn the poet was a Vietnam War
vet and so the lien is the Vietnam part
of his half Vietnamese half Puerto
Ricans son and that's how I got my name
how lean mine would mean and I'm already
scared at the syntax of this question
how old a man while Miranda changed the
world I don't know how he changed it
we're just getting started
how does lin-manuel Miranda write music
very slowly
by talking to himself in front of a
piano until it feels true and then he
writes it down it's as simple as that
and it's as complicated as that Carolyn
Manuel Miranda dance you tell me tell
Fosse let's go